eight-time russian champion peter
fiddler commentator extraordinaire peter
this event wasn't what you wanted give
us a sense of
this this particular game first of all
yeah this is kind of regrettable because
that was a very good chance to you know
and end the tournament on a on a
slightly more cheerful note and uh
i think i played fine up to a point but
i had a brief talk with leonard outside
and he showed me some computer
evaluations and it's extremely annoying
that i think it's like a function of how
the the beginning of the tournament went
for me that
i just couldn't like convince myself to
do things i knew in my heart to be right
and i think i was still probably close
to winning even after not doing that but
specifically the position
i
do to kind of give some kind of a you
know context with the board the position
after
after uh rook h1 bishop g5
if we could uh bring it up on there we
have it we're right here uh
yeah first of all bishop takes you could
say
bishop to xf6 is such a florida move
right
a what florida
it's such a florida move like where you
get that one
and jeffrey thought for like 40 minutes
so i had time to describe it to myself
and i
i thought it's just such a like
retirement village
[Laughter]
now we understand the retirement village
it's just lazy man just go
just go i live in florida now i know
retiring in florida
that was one of the reasons i was really
looking forward to saying that
but yeah just go knight f1 in that
position and play but also jeffrey was
playing much faster than me and this is
like move 13 and i had like 40 minutes
left
i'm sure i'm better but i don't know how
clear it is because now i guess the g3 i
still haven't have no direct threats
it's not like i'm going to be winning in
three moves here uh but yeah i mean
clearly this is the way to go for
maximum and then jeffrey sort of
re-gifted the game back to me because i
think after takes takes knight g4
uh like in his sport i would have just
insta
i would have taken on g4 c3 played 95 in
long castles
in about three seconds flat
and that position i mean i i do have an
extra pawn but tonight what i missed
originally i was kind of happy about
this and then no no you take on c3 first
of course
oh you need to break this open otherwise
there's really no counterplay and then
you go 95 and after queenie two i'm such
a you know for me bishops are always
better than knights so i immediately i
kind of took on c4 in this position in
my mind and that bite is much much
better but what you do here is you
castle and you get the knight from e5 to
c5
and i don't think i can stop it and uh
with the knight on c5 it's not that the
counter play is very strong i will put
the bishop on b3 there is never going to
be any threats to my king i don't think
but
it's kind of difficult for me to push
with the knight on c5 kind of keeping
keeping an eye on things
uh and i've
as jeffrey was thinking i i kept on like
running this person in my in my head and
i thought okay i mean i i have more
pawns it's excellent but
uh how easy will this be to win and i
came to the conclusion that
probably not easy at all
and uh
the one thing that was kind of cheering
me up in that during that process was
that jeffrey continued thinking and i
could see that he wasn't really very
enthused about this but bishop takes h4
i think is just
is just a horrible decision i you just
have to take take your lumps there the
opening did not go to plan so
yeah and and here
uh it's kind of hard to criticize what i
did but i think just playing g3 here
effectively wins the game as well
uh
yeah bishop six i think takes takes a
four we don't need to even discuss this
position the reason i decided not to was
that it allows an end game i wanted to
like i thought i will just give mate in
the game uh and here black can take on
jifago queen g5 check
but
we take we play a four and after b7 we
have a very important move rook h5 which
i i had seen it's not like i didn't see
it uh
and uh i mean this is about as winning
an endgame as you can have with dreams
material equal
because you know black maybe doesn't
lose any material immediately like rook
d87 bishop f6 bishop f8 g7 somehow
but i don't even need to collect
anything like every single piece of mine
is better than every single piece of his
absolutely so yeah like i knew this was
kind of close to winning and then
instead you can play
uh takes xbox six here
and this maybe would have been playable
sorry bishop six in this position yeah
in this position yeah but unfortunately
i think after f4
the king just never gets to see a this
is the problem if black could castle
coincide here black would be completely
fine but with the queen on g4 i don't
think the king the king ever gets to c8
and in fact i'm going to start playing
e5 f5 any moment now you know the true
benign style
uh and yeah this is just much better
than what i did but the one that really
hurts this okay i can understand i
wanted to keep the queens on and i
really thought 93 was like borderline
winning
but then he found this very interesting
idea of h5h4 which i don't know if it's
good but it's a very uh interesting try
to keep like some control over the dark
squares and here my plan when i was as i
was playing rookie c1 my plan was to
wait until he plays bishop g5 which i
think is the strictly the only move in
the position because otherwise knight to
5 will win the next move um so rook he
won as i played bishop g5
and my plan was just to come to the
board and play 45 in this position
and then i wore e5 yeah and then i
talked myself out of it
and
this is just heartbreaking
because
you know i i knew this was correct i
knew this is how you're supposed to play
these positions and then i started
calculating g4 and i mean d5 knight e4
now g5 bishop d5 i think is completely
lost i don't think you can hold this
uh
but d594 and i played king of fade for
him in this position i think i think
king of fate was worrying me more than
castles although castles also doesn't
lose by force
and i started thinking like if i don't
give mate immediately how winning is
this uh because the the files in front
of the black king are
closed for now
opening up the f file or the g file is
not going to be very easy and if you
imagine black like landing the king on
g7 and then starting to like take on e3
and play bishop b6
it's so it's a solid position like black
obviously needs a few tempe but
yeah but the machine says 96 more or
less wins in this position apparently
which i did not really understand from
it even even now
after i've
i have after i've seen it on a computer
screen i i still don't understand why
it's so crushing like bishop b6 for
instance
take some queen takes e6 for instance
but obviously machine is never wrong
about these things and if it says it's
winning it's winning but
uh
it's it's kind of really upsetting not
to not to make moves like this when
uh you know every i i i used to be a
good dynamic player and uh
like everything screamed at me that like
you have to
quinta g6 is a cop-out i'm still much
better in the end game but it's a
cop-out
and just do this and then think later
and then collect the emergency price too
i don't know
uh
yeah well and
and then i think a very very big chance
was missed uh when i kind of
i missed some i
for once i decided to trust my hand
because i think i kind of refocused and
played this
quite well and i for instance i really
like the move king a2 uh which i think
against like seven minutes
is a very very strong choice because
uh we're keeping keeping things together
and we're passing the move to uh to
black and it's difficult to make to make
a choice and it might the point of king
a2 is i'm sidestepping like not a 3d2
counterplay
i'm making sure that 92 is never a check
so it's a very useful kind of a holding
move passing the decision to jeffrey and
the decision is annoying enough that he
actually gave me the b7 pawn here
and then i just thought i was winning by
force and i decided not to calculate any
further and here yeah knight a5 i think
is much stronger than knight c5
because i as i didn't realize at the
time we're threatening a 496.95
f4
knight c6 ah that's a very nice yeah so
like h2f4 i'm instantly i'm instantly
winning wow because i actually i get rid
of all of my weaknesses i trade off some
passive pieces and
we're two we're too up in an end game
and the threat of f4 basically means
that jeffrey doesn't have time to play
rook h2 and if he doesn't have time to
play rook h2 i'm two pawns up and i
should be able to stabilize but i missed
i thought knight c5 was just winning i
calculated knight c5 rook h2 rg1 and
uh after f6 basically what i missed is
the mobius p3 as we as played in the
game
i thought he has to play king d6 here as
as after rg7 check
uh and after king d6 we take king c5 and
very very importantly i can go 95 bishop
g5 knight c7
and uh
i thought this was very strong even
actually even here after king d4 i don't
know why i thought this was so good
looking in this position but i will win
the a7 pawn so at least you know you
know this will be a race at least
uh but in the game i end up with those
stupid pieces on b3 and c3 i'm not even
better i think after brooke j b3 you
know i have to be careful not to be
worried let's hold for a second because
the exchanges did happen in the other
game that is going on right now the only
game left the queens were exchanged
after rook to e1 fabi found nothing
better
than to take on c4
and go to this end game where his pawn
looks firmly blockaded in this double
rook ending so peter you you end up
drawing this game how do you assess your
tournament overall and looking forward
to future future events
well i've
it's
had i won today i would have said you
know it's kind of reasonably well
salvaged
and in general the second half i
resembled a human being in most games
but
uh yeah it hasn't been an unqualified
success let's put it like this and uh
um
[Music]
yeah i'm very disappointed uh
with uh with with my play here i think
uh i haven't really managed to play a
single game sort of from start to finish
without without glitching
uh i've come close in some games but uh
40 moves without without something that
i myself evaluate very very harshly
seems to be
you know beyond me for this particular
event which is
annoying
but i mean it's it's over now and uh
there is time to reflect and regroup and
uh you know think about
uh
where to go next all right we'll let you
reflect and regroup we know you'll be
back and we'll
look forward to that thank you
thank you peter